popular TV series can become victims of
their own success cast and crew makes
such compelling television that some
fans just can't wait to find out what
happens next on their favorite shows and
will go to any lengths to get that
information that's why some productions
have tried to thwart these spoilers at
great effort and expense by actually
scripting and filming scenes they never
even intend to use here's a look at
shows that tried to throw off the
spoilers with fake footage and of course
real spoilers ahead The Sopranos The
Sopranos had one of the most famous and
maddening final moments in TV history as
gangster Tony Soprano sits in the diner
with members of his family and journey's
don't stop believin plays on the jukebox
the scene abruptly cuts to black mid
scene many viewers assume that this
sudden ending reflects Tony Soprano's
fate that he was killed by one of his
many enemies in the decades since The
Sopranos wrapped up creator David Chase
has been reluctant to spell out exactly
what became of Tony but in 2016 he told
deadline that he shot a different ending
because the production of experience
problems with people trying to invade
and get our scripts the scene was shot
but the details were so inconsequential
and destined to be discarded as a ruse
that chase couldn't even remember all
the details he tried to recall Tony goes
back to the BOD of being strip club and
has an argument with Silvio or something
well it couldn't have been because he
was in the hospital well anyway it was a
fake ending that we shot just to throw
people off lost john locke played by
terry o'quinn
met a sad fate on lost horrific lea
strangled to death by Michael Emerson's
Ben Linus but the show played fast and
loose with time and space so Locke was
still part of the series even after the
revelation that the body in the casket
in the funeral parlor was his or maybe
not after a major plot in which Locke
led a group looking to take down Jacob
his body was shown rolling out of a
cargo box heroic leader Locke was
actually the shape-shifting man in black
and the real Locke was death to throw
everybody for a loop or maybe to keep
their options open The Lost crew shot a
couple of other scenes in which the dead
man in the coffin isn't locked but
Sawyer and Desmond instead he was a man
of faith he was
a much better man
but I will ever be sex in the city HBO's
Sex in the City was an updated urban
take on the romantic comedy but a
romantic comedy nonetheless and it ended
like one Sarah Jessica Parker's
character Carrie Bradshaw wound up with
her on-again off-again guy mr. big and
returned to New York after a spell in
Paris the day after the finale aired in
2004 Parker told USA Today that three
different endings had been shot with the
one true wrap-up kept the secret the
abandoned endings which Parker called
just silly involved Carrie returning to
New York alone or with artist boyfriend
Alexander Petrovsky imagine the fan
uproar if that happened Dallas a massive
hit during the 1979 to 1980 TV season
the CBS primetime drama Dallas entranced
millions with the story of wicked Texas
oil tycoon jr. Ewing played by Larry
Hagman and his family and associates in
the cliffhanger third season finale as
jr. got ready for bed one night someone
shot him and left him for dead
it was a shocking TV moment and over the
summer seemingly all of America debated
who shot jr. as pretty much every
character on Dallas had a motive so to
keep fans guessing in case a cast or
crew member leaked the details multiple
resolutions to the cliffhanger were shot
so who really shot jr. turns out it was
his mistress and sister-in-law Kristin
Shepard portrayed by Mary Crosby The
Simpsons 15 years after who shot jr. the
sixth season of The Simpsons and it with
a similar cliffhanger episode in which
Springfield nuclear power plant bossy
Montgomery burns is shot by an
unidentified assailant and collapses
onto a sundial with his arms pointed to
the W and s pretty much everybody in
Springfield was a suspect but in the
seventh season premiere infant Maggie
Simpson was revealed as the shooter
while there were clues that the baby did
it
Simpsons writer David Mirkin told The AV
Club that he purposely wanted to
construct it so that it made you think
that Smithers had done it as discussed
on a Simpsons DVD commentary track
scenes of many characters pulling the
trigger were created including Moe
Barney and Santa's Little Helper to fool
leakers further a completely separate
ending was produced in which Smithers
actually did shoot mr. burns The Walking
Dead the sixth season of The Walking
Dead built up to the arrival of negan
portrayed by Jeffrey Dean Morgan in the
original comics written by Robert
Kirkman negan almost immediately kills
Glenn with Lucille his barbed wire
wrapped baseball bat with the show
follow suit or would another member of
Rick's gang ambushed by the Savior's
meet their doom instead in the
mid-season finale
negan killed somebody the show cut to
black before we could find out viewers
had to wait awhile to learn that Glen
and Abraham were indeed at the other end
of Lucille the showrunner Scott Gimple
wanted to keep that eventual outcome
secret which was especially difficult
because the Walking Dead deals with
incredibly bold and intrusive spoiler
hunters in fact camera-equipped drones
have been spotted flying over the set in
order to preserve the big reveal the
show shot 11 different Lucille related
deaths one for each character
Game of Thrones while The Walking Dead
crew has to deal with intrusive drones
Game of Thrones has to deal with
paparazzi using long-range camera lenses
to snap pictures of the show in progress
in the lead-up to the show's seventh
season in 2017 producers filmed fake
scenes to fool those tricky
photographers and spoiler hungry fans
Kit Harington who stars as Jon Snow told
Jimmy Kimmel that the series shot three
scenes that weren't part of the show or
intended to be used at all we put
together people in situations where we
knew the paparazzi was around so they
take photos and that will count on the
internet to fake scenes for his part
Kimmel summed up what the process must
have been like for the cast and crew
what a pain in your ass that is thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]